I don't understand why we're doing this  we barely know these people  it's one day let's mix things up a bit  you're just happy you found your fan  club  I've been waiting six years for your  second book is it coming out soon I'm  working on it what do you do for money  then  you married rich  I actually came here looking for  inspiration  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  hear the punishment for any crime  committed  his death  wait  what would you say  but for a significant sum will build a  double to send in for your execution  oh  [Music]  it was just like oh my God  maybe think of it as a gift  it's like a new skin working into place  so you need to complete your  transformation  this is just a little girl  but I can take some blood  show me how strong you are  it's really disgusting  you could just sit there  and watch it happen  you know James do you worry they got the  wrong man